today I want to talk to you about how
you can stop being a perfectionist so
I'm a recovering perfectionist I like
things to be exactly as I want them you
know if something is one pixel off it
bothers me and I wanted to be fixed and
and that's held me back a lot in my
business measurement earlier years where
it would stop me from doing things
because I wanted to be perfect and until
it was perfect that wasn't going to
release it and because I could never get
it to be perfect nothing ever came out
and I feel like this hurts a lot of
entrepreneurs the thing that really
helped me get better is understanding
that there is no perfect this is a
struggle you want perfect right you want
it to be exactly perfect and because
there is no perfect you're constantly
stressing out on trying to get there so
there is no perfect your main goal is
just trying to be better than you were
yesterday and that really helped me
because I look at my youtube videos and
I look at my website and I look at my
team and I look at my relationship
nothing is perfect right you're always
going to be edited in your website
you're always going to be trying to make
your relationship better you're always
going to be improving your products and
services there is no perfect a lot of
people want to get started on YouTube
one and they're trying to make their
first video and they record it and then
look at it they don't like it so they
don't publish it and then they try to
record it again and it still isn't good
so they don't publish it and they never
actually publish anything because they
have these crazy high standards they
want it to be perfect that's never going
to get there and so then you don't end
up publishing anything and you don't
make any progress towards your goal well
you look at my end special series as an
example I start with an idea I made my
first video it was ok you guys loved it
thank you for that you gave me some
great feedback and it got better and I
added some theme music and I added the
shot of espresso and I've gotten better
every time I've done a video and so
that's the key you got to start it's
great to play and it's great to have
that bit of perfectionist that makes you
want to have high standards right on
that saying throw away all your
standards and just create crap you need
to have those standards but don't let
those standards get you in the way of
actually doing something in creating you
don't need to be perfect you just need
to be better than you were yesterday
believe so my question the day for you
guys is I'd love to know if you're a
perfectionist and if that has held you
back and what you've done about it I'm
really curious to find out leave in the
comments below and I'm going to join the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching he's to believe and i'll see
you soon